We wanWe wanTrump!t Trump!
- Le 6 j- Le 6 jvier 202anvier ,
impensl'impensle se prable se pt
à Washià Washiton.ngton.
- (foule- (foule USA! US): USA!!
- Fake n- Fake ns, no moews, no!
"Nous n "Nous nbandonne'abando,
nous ne nous ne derons jcéderona
n'arriven'arrive pas, onra pas,s
quand ilquand il a un vo y a un.
Nous allNous alls descenons dese
au Capitau Capite."ole."
Ne digé Ne digént pas srant pae
aux urneaux urne Donald s, Donae
la foulela foulee sympat de sym.
"Si vous"Si vouse vous b ne vous
comme decomme dediables,s diabl,
vous pervous perez votredrez vo"
- Freedo- Freedom!
- Des ma- Des mafestantsnifestas
lancent lancent assaut.l'assaut.
La forceLa forceu nombre du nom.
(cri)(cri)
Le CapitLe Capite est enole esti
peu aprpeu aprs 14 h.ès 14 h.
Rassemb Rassembs dans llés dane
pour cerpour cerfier le tifier e
présidenprésidenel...tiel...
les élusles élusrennent  prennee
ou se caou se caent.chent.
- Everyb- Everyby stay dody sta!
- Mike P- Mike Pce, le vence, l,
est escoest escoé.rté.
6 heures6 heurese violen de vio,
un défun défsécuritai sécuritae.
Dans le Dans le laware, Delawarn
dénonce dénonce insurrecl'insur.
"Notre d"Notre docratie émocratt
en ce moen ce mont une ament unn
sans présans prédent, qucédent,e
à rien à rien  ce que de ce queu
dans lesdans lesemps mod temps "
C'est l C'est lplus grae plus t
depuis qdepuis q l'arméeue l'are
a détruia détruile bâtit le bât,
durant ldurant lguerre da guerr.
PlusieurPlusieurheures as heure,
Trump deTrump dende aux mande as
de rentrde rentr chez euer chez,
en maien maintant quenant que
l'élecl'élecon a ététion a étéo.
La gard La gardnationale natioe
finit pafinit paarriver.r arriv.
Ce n'estCe n'estu'aux pr qu'auxs
du 7 jandu 7 janer que lvier que
de Joe Bde Joe Ben sera iden se.
- We are- We arell part all part
of the bof the bgest scaiggest .
- 140 po- 140 pociers soliciers,
5 person5 persons sont mnes son.
Plus de Plus de 0 person700 pers
sont incsont incpées pouulpées r
leur parleur parcipationticipat.
La démo La démoatie amécratie t
mise àmise à'épreuve l'épreuveLe
de l'assde l'asst du Capaut du e
de peserde peserur les p sur les
électionélection à coms, à comnr
celles dcelles dmi-mandae mi-ma.
Ici Yas Ici Yasne Khayamine Kh,
Radio-C Radio-Cada, Monanada, .